Okay,
we should be live here.
Me make sure that we have everything
that we need. Looks good.
I'm going to set the stream title.
Then we will get started with a good
five hour stream.
Think that is the plan for the day.
It's off.
game development.
Okay,
should be good.
We should
This should be decent, right?
Yeah. Let me switch the stream view
Set this up on the side
and uh I will explain what we're doing
now.
Okay.
So
we have um I've been working on some
small algorithm changes that are
targeting improving off policy drift
particularly for async and generally
stabilizing higher sample reuse. I ended
up searching like several dozen
different things. We ended up quite near
the original
which is actually a good thing. It's
very frustrating to not be able to
improve too much over original, but uh
it does sort of speak to uh how robust
our stack is that a lot of the problems
that are out there in the lit we've kind
of already addressed implicitly.
So
uh a lot of this has just been rock
shenanigans, just automating little
tests here and there and just letting
things run overnight. Um but we're back
to the original Perf and everything with
these improvements.
9957.
Okay,
that looks reasonable.
Interesting.
Okay. Very small diff. This is literally
the entire diff.
Uh this seems to be significantly better
stability at higher sample reuse.
I think we will we'll save the ablation
for now
for the very end
cuz we've ablated this significantly. I
think we're fine.
I think it might have over
compensated.
Was that fixed?
Uh, a combination of things. We had a
bug with important sampling. We had a
few different bugs to fix as well as a
couple small tweaks to the algorithm.
Let me make sure this isn't screwing us.
>> It does feel pretty dumb though to be
fair doing things this way when the
models are this dumb and they're also
like not they're faster but they're it's
still pretty slow to be working this
way. I'm going to be very happy to be
done with this and to be back on more
reasonable loop task.
So, what I want to do right is I just
want to land this patch as like a
narrowly scoped algo change. Make sure I
didn't break anything and then launch
some sweeps.
I don't think we want to drop is
I also can't be sitting here with the
runs.
It's just very irritating cuz this thing
just forgets [ __ ]
I just want to get something merged with
like clearly marked as experimental and
start testing this on other stuff.
Okay, so he doesn't have net hack for me
today. That's fine. Um, that's really
just me wanting to do net hack. Uh, it's
I don't need it today to be productive.
In fact, it's arguably better I do the
other M's today.
Well, hopefully we will figure this out
soon. Let's make the plan though for the
rest of today. Um,
our highest confidence other ends are
Maze and 2048. Hey, Volo,
we are cleaning up current ALGO changes,
trying to make sure I didn't screw
anything up, and then testing them on
harder things.
Do I need to rerun 2048 sweep is going
to be the question.
Bit ass man. This is like this is the
type of thing that just like exhausts
me. It's just like thing spins and spins
and spins and does dumb [ __ ] and like
it's annoying because it is still faster
to do stuff this way, but it's
incredibly frustrating.
Is incredibly frustrating.
Um,
okay. I we definitely we need some
faster tasks that are still high
confidence.
We probably should have like a five
minute 2048 or something like that.
The problem is you kind of need the
convergence guarantee.
Okay, we figure this out. We as quickly
as possible, we figure this mess out. We
get this onto latest branch with some
flags.
password guessing
um somewhere in there probably.
That's not like a considered a good
robust test or anything though.
We can run maze to see if we broke maze
for sure, but we need to reune for
async.
what interview
I did a podcast thing with. Was it
the information bottleneck? Okay.
Mhm.
Yeah. So, basically we picked we have to
just get this thing now.
Yeah, there's definitely some [ __ ]
here.
You need this correction for high RR.
Okay. But it's just implemented. [ __ ]
stupid is what is going on here.
Fine.
Yeah, it's just really implemented
stupidly. Okay.
How do you suggest tuning hypers with
protein
reward hypers?
No, jointly. You shouldn't have a crazy
number of reward hypers either. Chuck it
all into protein. You're good.
I'm trying to think how we test this in
a timely
a timely fashion.
I mean, I could also just stick
this on a box, right,
with eight GPUs
um for 2048.
there. That should be better. So, Mu on
re
I mean, I'll take that.
He's done some cool stuff.
LR.
Okay. So, this should be fine.
And then we have the correction
to move on.
We don't need this crap.
It snuck a bunch of [ __ ] in There.
It honestly is so exhausting, man. Like,
I just have not wanted to put in good
working hours because of this [ __ ]
Like, it feels like, oh, this is faster.
But then the thing is, if I get
exhausted because I just have to spend
so much of my time dealing with stupid
[ __ ] it's not good.
So, let's figure out what did we just
add here.
sucks the joy out of dev. Oh yeah. Oh
yeah.
I This basically just makes my job
[ __ ] miserable.
Like that's the only reason. If you find
yourself working fewer hours, it's
generally because your work sucks.
This thing is just [ __ ] dumb. I swear
it's really infuriating.
Like I don't know why I do this to
myself. I genuinely don't. It's like you
start off like, oh, you know, I'm going
to do this as a side project and
automate some basic experiments, but
then it like just completely falls on
its face and fails to do that. You see
like, oh, look, it solved like these 10
hard math problems. Surely you can use a
model to like automate a couple very
basic experiments and ablations over the
weekend and it just [ __ ] sucks every
goddamn time.
It's just deceptive because like it
works for a while but then inevitably
like they just make utterly stupid
errors, right?
I mean like they make 12year-old that
can't hold coherent train of thought
level errors.
sake. I'm dying here. This is just
awful.
It It is like a cold slot machine. It
is.
But the thing is like here's the thing.
I'm not even being [ __ ] and just
like, you know, now make me a game where
the platformer that like I'm precisely
describing at the code level exactly
what needs to happen and it's still
[ __ ] up.
Like it's literally if this delete this
block of code the if this keep this
block of code and it deletes both of
them or remove or deletes neither of
them.
[sighs]
Swear we're going to remember this whole
AI [ __ ] is the biggest goddamn con
job that Silicon Valley ever pulled.
I I just need to get myself I honestly
the main thing that I'm missing in order
to get this just do this myself is if I
could just have a consistent environment
with 30 second training
basically we've just it used to be
breakout but now breakout is too easy
because we solve breakout in a second we
need something that I can solve in like
30 seconds that's actually really
informing
Hey Jess. Uh, it's algorithmic changes
here. I'm super frustrated with this
crap though.
Okay, I genuinely do think though at
this point we need a better test end.
Like we have 2048 for now, which is good
for confirmation, but we need like we
need something that's just really
predictive of um like we need something
that's really predictive that we can
trade in 30
section loop engineering.
What does that even mean?
Like you'll notice here the total
changes I'm accepting from like this 3
days worth of stuff. And this is not
really even accepting as much as like
keeping under research flags for
testing. It's like 150 lines.
Tetris is fast. I don't know if Tetris
is a good confirmation.
It has exponential scoring and we kind
of wreck it as well.
I it the thing that's saddest is this
should be the perfect use case and that
it's like it's a set of pretty small
scope changes with like a bunch of
throwaway experiments just to sort of
figure out what is likely to be
a useful change or not. And it still
screws up too many things to do that
because you need to have at least some
level of consistency in your testing.
I think we definitely need to get this
on 2048.
Am I going insane or is it just It's
literally
I look up PO by mistake instead of PO
and there's some other dumbass algorithm
by the name. It's just Groc. It doesn't
matter. I've tried all the models. They
all suck. All right, the models are all
dumb. They all make the same types of
really stupid mistakes. The only
difference is whether I have to sit here
for 5 minutes or two hours between it
making really stupid mistakes.
It's still faster than me doing it
manually, which is why I'm dealing with
this mess. But it is infinitely more
frustrating.
That's it. There's no additional
subtlety to it. There's no additional
nuance. There's no like, could you
change the way you're using it this way
or that way? It's just dumb.
Okay. So, this is Where is the damn clip
factor? Unless I'm going nuts.
Yeah. So, we're double count. We are
double counting the
>> Okay, we do not want a double count
advantage, right?
Yeah, I forgot that this was applied as
a multiple. Right.
So, L clip.
Wait.
Clip.
No, it's not getting applied as a
multiple is it?
PRPO maximum. We propose
advantage times reward.
And then here's the clipped form. It's
already correct.
Thought that it doesn't get multiplied
though.
What? It just get used for clip, doesn't
it?
Wait, what are we defining?
R of T.
Where's R of T?
This just return.
Oh, wait.
Okay. Yeah. Okay, fine.
Um,
length normalized geometric. This is
what we want.
I need to I need to go through the math
of this, but I think this is what we
want, right?
But wait, aren't we already relying on
advantage to clip?
No, it doesn't give you the double-sided
clip.
It doesn't give you the double-sided
clip the PO does.
Okay, there's just a tricky bit of math
here, I think.
checker. We can try it. Jess, it's
selfplay though. Um so selfplay is
separate from core like end of testing.
Oh, is it fast chest the opponent?
We can try that.
Have to see the curve.
My head's going to [ __ ] explode with
this [ __ ] Um,
I've I've just spent so much time going
through this over the weekend already
and every time I think I understand this
stupid thing, it's like there's still
some dumb gap.
Like they do different things, but then
empirically neither of them work as they
actually are supposed to. So what the
hell's the point?
Jess, I've gone through this a million
times. I'm sure I'll go through it again
in a second, but like hang on.
Dude, I [ __ ] can't with this thing. I
swear. I just can't.
Let me see.
I'm trying to think what is the most
productive way for me to do this.
>> [sighs]
>> trying to write an equivalence.
going to drive me insane.
We have a few things we've clearly
found, but this is still a mess.
Hang on. [sighs and gasps]
Even makes sense.
This changes the target, doesn't it?
Working on annoying math.
for
uh puffer RL
100.
It even makes sense. So J uses a frozen
target, right?
Why does this predict the clipped
target?
Actually, that's a good question.
Why don't we auto abort a sweep run on
Nan?
Nan loss.
You could
This has to be regressed against a live
V I think
is the issue.
These puzzle pieces just don't go
together nicely.
The [ __ ] paper am I looking at? This is
BPL.
Um, most of those papers with 10 people
is one person doing all the work and
then like a bunch of people [ __ ]
tagging on.
V trace came later.
Let's see.
No, ours is literally
Okay, we actually This is actually It's
kind of cool that this is actually a uh
durable. I actually thought that I'd
like replicated something else later. I
was kind of bummed.
It's supposed to be a strict
generalization unless I screwed
something up. I don't trust this thing.
There might be a small bug.
Yeah, puffer advantage is uh from way
earlier. Puffer advantage is well
supposed to be and presumably is in my
math
but bugged in the kernel. It's supposed
to be a strict generalization of J and V
trace.
Why does it not open a normal browser?
like
Okay. So, we we broke it in the port. My
research was correct. We broke it in a
port somewhere.
Oh, it just screwed this up though. I
see.
Okay, so this wasn't me. This was Grock
being dumb. We're fine.
Yeah, it literally Grock just introduced
a bug in the latest refactor that took
me 20 minutes. I
This is the last day of this. No matter
what, this is the last day cuz this is
just making me miserable.
Um I
Yeah.
I'm trying to think now what the target
did because there's this discrepancy
with the uh the value function.
>> Okay, so this is
an optimizing V.
Yeah. Um
the thing I'm confused now, right? So we
have I'm trying to resolve this
discrepancy in the algorithm that we
have. Um so we have a generalization of
GA and V trace. But the discrepancy I'm
realizing we have right is that VRE uses
a live value function.
uh they keep reestimating with the
latest value function whereas PO phrases
it
mean we have empirical results here
regardless I'd Okay.
The problem is this just keeps breaking
crap.
B trace is from Impala.
It's meant for off policy correction.
Um it's weaker than GE on policy. We
have evidence of that.
Yeah, but the thing is
there are lots of different conditions
to account for, right? So, are we
accounting for async training lag drift
or are we just going to account for like
sample reuse? It turns out that they
scale pretty differently.
Where's off Paul come from? V trace
comes from async training, but also you
get off policy from um just like after
your very first mini batch.
We can't get rid of this clip. I know,
but
freezes it.
I'll go to some extent.
You don't freeze in 40.
Thought we do freeze. Oh, no. Maybe we
do use live V in 40. Actually, I think
you're right.
We double counting or not? I can't tell
genuinely.
batch size effects async.
Um,
it seems to me Oh, we should also double
check how it was in 40.
I think we did use live V.
Let's double check actually.
Would be a good baseline.
The hell? Why is it open via Studio? The
[ __ ]
What even is that?
anthropic market
as if it's solved. I you know I don't
whatever you stream on Twitch. Yeah, I'm
on Twitch and uh YouTube.
They just trend anything developed. All
right, Martin, you're like on a totally
different planet right now because if
you try GRPO in like nonLMRL, you'll see
it's an awful awful algorithm. Um, so
like that's not remotely the progress.
Like
the LLM RL is kind of like glue sniffer
RL in the sense that they're solving a
really restricted version of the problem
where you can't do anything remotely
interesting or useful.
uh the important sampling not being
wired correctly. Jess,
so the formulation was correct, but it
was not wired correctly.
use gym. Are these LMs allergic?
Well, that's just like [ __ ] if
you're trying to do anything high perf
because like Jim just caps you a
thousandx lower. Period. No way around
it.
Yeah, I mean, but they will just
recommend you whatever the popular thing
is. Like they'll very happily tell you
to go build every website with Node and
then 3JS for fancy graphics you don't
need and like let's fork in Tailwind and
like everything else. They're terrible
programmers.
What did you No, Jess. The live V was
fine in both cases.
It's the importance that was weird.
I'm so sick of these models just doing
dumb [ __ ] man.
Yeah. Well, I mean, I I don't know what
to do about that, right? Like,
congratulations. Like, you learned that
all of modern software engineering is a
lie. Very very obviously a lie. if you
happen to look at things. And then these
language models have all of that crap
baked And
You You don't even want to know how much
money they spend on RL tasks.
I think I have an idea of what it's
doing.
I think I know what's happening here.
Do we have prior on?
No.
This thing.
They great. What?
They don't know all like they don't know
Jack most of the time. That turns out
it's the issue with coding out. I mean,
they don't work. Like, I don't know what
to tell you. They just like they just
fall off of chains of logic that a
12-year-old could follow.
You get this mix of like a really really
specific technical knowledge, but then
always presented very confidently, even
when it's flatout [ __ ] wrong, which
it is a reasonable fraction of the time.
And then like sometimes they get like
very deep stuff right, but then they
make like 12year-old level logic errors
and the result is just about the most
frustrating possible work experience
imaginable.
Like these things very clearly are not
generally intelligent.
What interview? Oh, um, uh, it's on the
information bottleneck. If you Google
it,
I have, uh, an interview out
and go listen to that.
No, just like on Google, man. Just
Google it.
It could be we just need to massively
retune hypers.
Yeah, exactly. That's why it doesn't
work.
Creating reliable. Yeah, exactly. And
that's why it doesn't work.
See, the problem
the problem is actually it's like it's
not like but these systems seem to work
super well. Like the issue you see is
that just a lot of people that are in
like very very well- paid positions in
companies that you'd expect to be very
very knowledgeable about programming and
their specific discipline just have
absolutely no idea what they're doing.
And by comparison, like yeah, you can
write put a really stupid language model
next to them and they look pretty
decent.
Like I don't know what to tell you. It's
just genuinely the case that there are
people that are making like $2 million a
year as uh principal engineers at or
higher at like major companies who I
would just straight up rather have a
decent undergrad than them.
Although some of them I'd just straight
up rather like have a not even decent
undergrad than them.
Actually, there's some of them I'd
rather just have nobody because they do
negative work.
But like, you don't have to take my word
for it. You can just go read publicly
available code from people who you'd
expect to know better and see that it's
10,000 lines of garbage when it should
be 500 lines.
Like go look at anything open sourced by
Google.
Bro,
I can't believe.
Yeah. Okay, cool. It tried to just do
It tried to just do RL with zero
gradient.
Good job.
More intelligent. It just tried to do RL
like deleting the policy gradient term.
What are we working on today?
We are attempting to work on an
algorithmic change. Um, the end thing is
going to look very similar to the
starting point, but the thing is
it's very difficult to work through this
mathematically and also there's a bunch
of buggy crap that's going on. So yeah,
it's tough. Um the crux of it is robust
integration of important sampling with
the current thing
uh and fixes to clipping changes to the
way we're computing value function.
Wait, what does it mean proportional to
one?
I don't understand what to do.
Uh, I've tried basically everything.
This is still just the PO clip. You
still need that.
Yeah, it's just like
I'm having difficulty here with this
type of work I'm doing because it just
keeps doing idiotic things.
Like I'm giving very precise
instructions and it's just doing random
idiotic things.
V trace.
Yeah. So V trace is it's from the Impala
line of work. Um it's used in high
throughput asynchronous settings and we
are introducing an asynchronous setting
in Puffer 5. So it makes sense. The
problem is that the Impala objective,
from what I've seen, is just much weaker
than the PO objective.
Oh, hang on.
We have to make sure now we could have
this bug.
Priority drive sampling is computed from
the same advantage tensor.
Uh yeah, it's supposed to be built on
the advantage function, but priority is
something separate entirely.
Priority does not have to do with
staleness or uh offpaul correction
like lag. The priority sampling is just
straight up to deal with um like sparse
data and differing data quality.
I'll be right back. Let me use the
restroom real quick.
Wait,
wait. Pi over pi old.
Why is it defining three [ __ ]
policies?
We have three.
Why do we have three policies?
Yeah. Yeah. I I I screwed my question
up. Hang on. I have it backwards.
But I there's a distinction here I need
to understand
because I don't know why you're ever
using like the policy at the start of
optim epoch for anything, right? Why
aren't you just using the fresh policy
always?
I understand why you use the rollout
policy. I don't understand why you use
the uh
Wait, we can't even compute those, can
Okay.
like now we have something that I can't
even get it right Because
This is awful. What the hell?
That's [ __ ] terrible.
So presumably this is just for like mini
batches or whatever.
Mini batch comes in.
I think it's fine the way I wrote it
then.
Yeah. No, this thing is wrong. Okay. So
let's see.
I'm going to let this do this in the
meantime while I think about this.
I think it's confused because
impala you're supposed to just get a
batch of data to use
and then you use it once
or like you get a mini batch to use I'd
suppose.
Uh, this is separate.
The Impala math is different.
It's also just a really sketchy
algorithm by comparison.
So if you if your batch of if you get a
batch of data in that is equal to the
size of your mini batch, then yes. But
in practice, you never get that ever.
And like if you set it up to force that,
you're just like making your [ __ ] more
async and more off Paul. It was just
really damn sketchy. Okay.
impala is only for async.
You would never do impala without async
cuz all the coefficients cancel out.
This just seems really specific and
shitty.
I've never seen like PO plus B trace in
the same thing.
Well, I'm pretty sure literally nobody
does this.
Citing the worst library in existence is
not great.
That's immediately worthless.
I mean, I see our lib immediately
worthless.
It would be the lambda term, wouldn't
it?
It should decrease our trust in lambda,
right?
how far the residuals allowed to
propagate. Okay.
Yes, async is async in this context
means that the uh the policy that is
collecting the data is different from
the policy even at the first step of
optimization. We have a different access
of async which is with the environment
that is still synchronous with respect
to optimization. That one is already
handled by our nice architecture. There.
doesn't have to wait for grading step.
Yeah.
Doesn't have to wait. Yes.
I just don't understand, man.
They look incredibly similar, but then
the more you dig into them, it's like I
understand what PO does.
I definitely ran some experiments on
this.
Reinforcement for multi- aent with
asynchronous.
That seems much
much much more than what we need here.
There's some other thing that I'm
missing here.
Fresh importance weights should be fine.
Live V should be fine.
Yeah, we already got rid of this.
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh my god. If this is on, I'm going to
rage so much.
God damn it, man. I hate language models
so much. It just I would have never made
that error ever.
Okay, I think that this is going to
significantly
revise my opinion downward
of using these stupid things in any
capacity whatsoever
for orchestrating research and
ablations.
at sample factory.
We have different um Buddha streams. I
don't know what you mean by that.
I mean, we just we have this on
different CUDA streams.
Actually, this is ours are better
because we have policy on um
Yeah, ours are actually ours is better
than this. We have a different axis of
we have another axis of parallelism.
And actually this thing I actually took
this for granted that this was correct
for the longest time. Uh it turns out
this is not optimal.
You need the other axis of parallelism.
You can check the architecture and what
we've written about it.
Rerun all the damn experiments, man. So
annoying.
Hang on. Clipping
PPO.
Okay, I just missed that that they that
the result closed that much.
Okay, this was the main thing. I think
that we can have some confidence now.
Okay,
we have not come up with anything to
replace this with.
We should actually test though whether
we need to with Muan.
Mulan might just do this for us with
momentum.
They normalize advantages by mini batch
in this.
And I think it's on by default, right?
Now, we're not going to do these super
long experiments.
5090 is the best GPU to use for
iteration like this.
Okay, cool.
Going to run a few experiments like
this.
I will be right back real quick.
two star of the puffer. It does help me
out a lot.
This is local. Well, rather this is um
puffer hosted
in the the warehouse.
should learn pretty quick to stop
running long experiments.
50 mil steps is enough for breakout
though.
50 mil steps also we can do in 1 second.
Look or 40 mil 43 mil steps in under a
second. See
I'm trying to think what I want to do
about this.
See whether any of this holds up.
These aren't great so far, right? What
was it? 639.
Reward variance is probably fine. Hey
Daniel. Um I basically been getting
trolled all day by dumb things, but we
have a version of the code that's close
to correct.
Uh I'm working to see whether there are
any small improvements we can make on
hypers.
It's basically pretty close to original
now. This one's actually pretty good
here.
Yeah. So, I have to let this run for a
little bit. These are quick. See if we
get any better hypers and we will go
from there.
Okay. So, we do this. We're going to
check this once we have some better
results, right?
We'll check this.
We will
And then what we've landed then so Muan
re needing ablation all of this mind you
but we'll land Muan re
trace
We can actually get these ablations
rerun on breakout after this. So, I
think we just clean it up.
It's already four. So, yeah, let's just
aim to get this cleaned up,
uh, merged into a branch,
and then start the ablation runs.
Yeah, I mean we're starting to get some
reasonable things because this is just
slightly too big of a policy, I would
imagine. Yeah,
that's fine. Always takes it a while to
find runs. U I'm trying to think what I
want to do in the meantime.
We'll just let this run because these
are quick, right?
And then
Not bad.
It's also without prioritization which
could potentially help a little bit.
Huge fan of puffer. Working on first RL
test.
Real world case you've done. Saw this
puffer drive in the repo. Uh I mean it
depends what you mean by real world,
right? Like professionally we've done a
whole bunch of different things. So I
have limited ability to share some of
those.
If you want just a few real world
looking ends
like drive is on the website.
This is used commercially
or professionally I should say. I don't
know whether they're selling stuff
around this yet.
Um and then we also have this drone.
Drone is really cool.
So watch this. This is a single policy.
I hit tab on this thing.
Single policy has a lot of different
modalities.
Yeah,
it's kind of funny because like as far
as learning problems go, a lot of the
game problems are just way harder to
learn than driver drones are. Why we use
them?
They end up harder, but also faster for
better iteration and um
more interpretable a lot of the time.
Let's see. So, we've got some two second
runs in here.
1.7.
Okay. I mean, this is getting better.
Definitely getting better.
Also, this is without ability to use
priority at all.
And without reward normalization,
presumably we'd want reward norm.
That's good. Yeah.
Ben's been doing a great job on that as
That's the P40. Good luck with that.
But I guess with puffer, you can at
least do something. Not ideal, but you
can do something.
Okay, these look kind of okay so far.
these runs.
I'll let it run 400 total.
It'll only be a couple minutes and then
we will from there
and continue.
What am I currently doing? Um,
well, I'm currently waiting for a few
more runs to finish from retuning hypers
with vrace.
And it looks like okay, not amazing so
far.
Yeah, it looks okay. Not amazing so far.
Um, and then we're going to get
we're going to get this integrated with
I guess the reward normalization.
We'll get a clean commit of this to a
branch and then we'll just get a bunch
of experiments going. Think that's
probably it.
Now I think of these changes
live V is fine.
Advantage norm is going to have to be a
bigger test. I do think we can probably
test VR out.
probably just here
like on breakout
which would be nice.
I said we're going to let it just finish
400 to be clean and then we're going to
we'll have this evaluate on uh to see
what actually replicates
we go from there.
Watch what I do personal work. A lot of
people do that. There is cool science
that happens occasionally.
A lot of breakthroughs are just made on
stream.
Sometimes it's just getting trolled by
uh random things. This morning was
particularly obnoxious,
but uh this is essentially just live
streamed RL research on Puffer is Perf
RL library.
And there's a combination of
research and
low-level dev simulation work
full stack of RL really.
Okay, this is enough. So we can just
kill this
Oh, perfect. Yeah, I've got um like 10
minutes probably.
I forgot how to do a thing. All right.
Well, we'll get it set up nicely.
We'll get it set up very nicely.
Interesting.
We can grab seed one, I suppose, for
now.
All the details are on puffer.ai as
well.
Lots of devs in there. This is all open
source work.
Educational materials as well. It's all
free.
This might need an LR return.
Probably does.
Oops.
Need to replay V trace a little bit.
else that we need to ablate?
I think that's it.
We should also try without reward clip.
Without reward clip would be
interesting.
Okay, so those two ablations are going
to take a while to run. Um, and
basically the goal is just going to be
to get a clean merge on these. The hope
will be that vrace does something in at
least the obvious setting where it
should and muan rail does something in
the obvious setting where it should. It
doesn't hurt us in the settings where it
shouldn't. I'll have to think about a
few other things, but that is
that is pretty much it.
Um
I think I'm going to call it. I think
I'm going to call it because I have to
go in three minutes anyways.
Um, how long I've been live today?
I mean, today was an obnoxious day to be
fair. Yeah, almost five hours of this.
This was super super obnoxious today.
I think that's fine. We'll get all this
stuff finalized tomorrow. I will keep
running a few little experiments uh just
as stuff finishes here. And uh we'll
probably at some point I'll set aside a
little bit of time to get 2048 sweep set
up, but this should be stable enough to
for us to use and do things on.
And uh yeah, we'll continue from here.
So
for anybody who's new around here, thank
you for tuning in. I stream pretty much
all of my dev. Sometimes it's chill,
sometimes not so chill, but it's all
here.
You can follow my stuff at puffer.ai.
Start the repo. It's free. Really helps
us out. Um, join Discord if you want to
get involved with dev.
And you can follow me on X for more RL
content. I stream here on X, YouTube,
and Twitch as well. They can watch on
your platform of choice.